THE UNICORNS OF THE SEA!
They're a real thing and they make me so excited
I might pee myself.
Hello hello friends Laci Green here for DNews.
No new studies for you today, just a loving
celebration of another neato animal in the
sea: the narwhal.
This is a rare whale that lives in Arctic
waters with a long horn-like tusk that juts
from the head -- a tusk that can grow to be
10 FEET LONG!
In addition to "the unicorn of the sea" the
narwhal has also been referred to as "the
corpse whale" because its spots kind of look
like livor mortis - that patchy discoloration
that can happen after death.
Although, as the narwhal ages, it gets more
and more white.
For centuries the narwhal has been famous
not for its color but for that TUSK, which
has been the source of all kind of folklore
and legends.
It may have been the original inspiration
for the beloved fictional unicorn and people
believed the tusk had magical healing powers.
They believed it so strongly, in fact, that
in the Middle Ages, the tusk of a narwhal
was worth 10x its weight in gold!
The high demand has posed a threat to the
species actually, so....that's not cool.
The source of the Narwhal's fame, the tusk,
is actually A TOOTH.
Craziest tooth you'll ever see my friends,
and it's the only tooth the Narwhal grows.
Although, very rarely, a second tooth will
grow.
This tooth is grown by most males and only
about 15% of the females....it grows directly
through the whale's upper lip and spirals
to the left.
Always to the left, possibly because it helps
maintain a more durable structure.
And it's not super hard either, the tusk is
bendy, it can bend about a foot in any direction.
What's interesting about the narwhal's tooth
is that it's anatomy is basically an inside-out
version of a human tooth.
While humans have the hard stuff on the outside
protecting the soft sensory tissue on the
inside, the narwhal has the hard stuff on
the INSIDE with the sensitive layers on the
outside.
There's a reason for this madness.
The sensitive layer is covered with millions
of tiny holes which act as a sophisticated
sensor for the whale.
These holes lead to the nerves which allow
the narwhal to sense the water's pressure,
temperature, how salty it is.
Good things to have for survival, which is
why it's not clear why female narwhals are
less likely to have one.
The function of the tusk is still being studied
because they're pretty mysterious creatures
that are hard for scientists to observe.
The scientific consensus at this point is
that the tusk is a sexual trait, kind of like
a lion's mane.
It may be there to attract a mate, to display
dominance, or perhaps even for communication.
Narwhals do touch tusks...but it's not in
a violent way.
That would probably hurt anyway, given how
many nerve endings cover the tusk.
Can you imagine banging up a sensitive organ?
NO THANKS.
So folks, what's your favorite animal in the
sea?
Tell me about it and maybe we'll throw a little
lovefest for them here on DNews.
Thanks for watching, I'll see you next time.